hello I'm Hank green and you were
watching truth or fail the drugs edition
just glamour
truth or feelings constituent parts do
not condone or encourage the use of
illegal drugs do not do drugs because
drugs were a bad idea but that doesn't
mean they aren't interesting truth or
fail is a very simple little YouTube
game I'm gonna tell you two statements
that's four I'm gonna tell you two
statements about the history of drugs
and drug culture and all you have to do
is click on the true statement or you
fail
round one one when an organization
tested hundreds of thousands of random
$1 bills in America they discovered that
four out of every five those $1 bills
had traces of cocaine on it or fact two
kinder eggs those delicious little
chocolate eggs with toys in the middle
are illegal in America because the
government fears that people will try to
smuggle drugs inside of them
[Music]
you